on part en russie où les partisans
d'alexei navalni se prépare à une
nouvelle journée de mobilisation pour
appeler à sa libération l'opposant
vladimir poutine est incarcéré pour
avoir violé à plusieurs reprises les
conditions d'une peine de prison avec
sursis
les protestataires ont commencé à se
rassembler à moscou une manifestation
non autorisée par les autorités qui ont
ordonné la fermeture des restaurants et
des magasins du centre de la capitale
la semaine dernière les manifestations
pour appuyer alexeï navalni s'était
soldée par plusieurs arrestations
on prend tout de suite la direction de
moscou pour retrouver notre
correspondant antoine clé enfin bonjour
vous êtes à moscou la manifestation a
commencé quelle est l'atmosphère sur
place
eh bien depuis un peu plus de deux
heures manifestants et policiers jouent
au chat et à la souris en effet le lieu
initial de rassemblement qui devait qui
devait se tenir au niveau de la place de
la loubianka symboliquement devant le
siège du fsb et est vraiment devenu
inaccessible en raison de la forte
présence policière une pas une présence
policière beaucoup plus importante que
la semaine dernière un résultat une
quelques dizaines de minutes avant le
début officiel de cette de ce
rassemblement non autorisé
il a été décidé de changer l'endroit
bleus de l'endroit de rassemblement à
cette station de métro de souraïev kaya
où nous nous trouvons maintenant même
s'il y a quelques minutes on a appris
que l'endroit de ce rassemblement était
encore modifié et il a maintenant lieu à
la prochaine station de métro à quelques
centaines de mètres d'ici alors ces
dernières quarante minutes que nous nous
trouvons ici nous avons pu observer
plusieurs arrestations en effet
maintenant tous les jours qui arrivent
via cette station de métro se dirige à
pied vers donc le lieu normalement le
lieu final de cette manifestation
alors dans deux jours alexeï navalni va
être jugé vous l'avez évoqué sur la
violation les violation de sa période de
probation sera donc dans deux jours si
la peine de prison avec sursis ou une
partie de cette peine sera commuée en
peine de prison ferme voilà ce qu'on
peut dire à l'heure actuelle pour cette
réunion ce rassemblement moscovite qui
ne fait donc que commencer
merci beaucoup antoine cabot pour tous
ces précisions directeur ou ce que nous
allons suivre évidemment ces événements
avec vous tout au long de la journée